prendre son temps faux-pas sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél
j'avais
[Musique]
dans une interview sentent importants
sur la structuration de
notre intellect par rapport à l'état des
choses qui vont pas rigoler
et effrayée par son intelligence par sa
propre intelligence et on est indulgent
envers sa propre connerie alors qu'on
pourrait très bien être être effrayé ça
serait plus juste par sa connerie et
être indulgent pour sa propre
intelligence et non je ne présente
jamais de cette façon là c'est toujours
c'est toujours le contraire
donc vous avez toutes les apparences du
bonheur et pourtant vous n'êtes pas
tellement
et bon monsieur
[Musique]
ne vous laissez pas prendre au charme de
synonymes maine de biran a écrit l'aîné
d'être moraux que ceux qui spéculent tu
fais tu fais toujours tu étais farce des
canulars ça fait longtemps que tu vas
voir et compter deux coups marrant mais
sûrement ça fait longtemps que j'en fais
plus parce que le
ça ça se répercute sur ma vie
professionnelle en crois que ce que je
fais des farces comme ça que je passe
mon temps comme les films même son nom
[Musique]
on avait eu mes pratiques pour chanter
une chanson dans un film un chanson
c'était toi toi toi toi quand nous
sommes sous notre toit juridique on
avait inventé un nouveau procédé tout à
fait perfectionniste et puis le bac
playback consistait un champ à chanter à
s'enregistrer mais à l'envers pour le
repas seul endroit après alors en effet
à prendre la chanson you tube yonne
yonne yonne yonne que non sur nous somes
joanes cette extension you tube
cet homme n'est pas un demeuré mental
c'est un ami qui a fait ça parce que
cela me gêne c'est chic et politique je
suis à gauche je vote communiste
je voudrais rajouter je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose
le je suis en train de fumer un gros
cigare ce cette petite maison que je
loue très cher tous les mois j'ai une
belle voiture et tout ça
dans la mesure où c'est possible je
gagne le plus d'argent possible on
pourrait se demander pourquoi ce vote
communiste parce que ça peut paraître
une situation paradoxale
je trouve que c'est moins paradoxale
pour moi de voter communiste que de voir
des gens qui gagnent le smic ou un peu
plus voter de la côte et relie mondaine
à saint tropez c'est pendant des années
ça c'était autre chose c'était
uniquement pour regarder les gens n'ont
pas du tout parce que je voulais les
mettre dans les films mais parce qu'il
représentait ce que les gens que je veux
maintenant je voulais maintenant mes
films considérés comme leur idéal non je
les vois ce que c'était idéal
tu as l'habitude autres moquer des gens
notre moquette ou non
je me dis moi mais protégé
[Musique]